9 30 here in new york a top
virologist in china defending her
research in the lab in the city of wuhan
where covet first emerged
the thinking that the virus leaked from
that lab is getting more and more
attention and now the former cdc
director robert redfield
sitting down for an exclusive interview
with fox
dr mark siegel spent two hours with him
over the weekend doctor good morning to
you
what did you learn bill a year and a
half ago dr robert redfield then
cdc director had a hypothesis about the
emerging virus
so did dr anthony fauci redfield felt
that the evidence pointed to a lab
manipulation and a leak
and fauci didn't there's an alternative
hypothesis that it went from a bat virus
got into a laboratory where
in the laboratory it was taught educated
it evolved so that it became a virus
that could efficiently transmit human to
human
my professional opinion as a virologist
is that's
where that's the hypothesis that i
support you know
other individuals tony fauci for example
would say that he
prefers to support that evolve from
nature i think those are the two
hypotheses
dr fauci has long believed the virus
came from an animal intermediary
a theory that gained the most traction
in the media and only recently
he has conceded that there might be
another explanation
i think tony is holding on to this
hypothesis
tightly now why why would that be
sometimes scientists when they get on
they bite into a bone on a hypothesis
it's hard for them to move on i guess if
i'm disappointed about anything about
the early scientific community
is that there seemed to be lack of
openness to pursue both hypotheses
dr redfield told me he had a higher
level security clearance than others on
the task force
working directly with the state
department and the national security
council
giving him early knowledge of the
virus's characteristics
that others on the task force just
didn't have
but much of what he reviewed was
classified he says data like this
needs to be shared wider to protect
americans
i think the first critical error was we
called this sars-like
covet ii is not sars-like and
by calling it sars-like we mounted a
public health response
that was mirrored off sars the problem
is covet's nothing like sars
this virus's transmission is largely
asymptomatic
so that strategy that we started in
january and february and finally figured
out as we got into march
that that wasn't the situation here that
probably most of the transmissions of
covet was from asymptomatic people
was flawed dr redfield claims it was a
big mistake his cdc team wasn't allowed
into the wuhan lab when the virus was
first
identified in january 2020.
he says he should have pushed harder to
get in right away
and the world health organization was
too compromised to help
i think they were highly compromised
clearly
they were incapable of
compelling china to adhere to the
treaty agreements that they have on
global health because they they didn't
do that
clearly they allowed china to define the
group of scientists that could come and
investigate that's not consistent with
their role
dr redfield told me he is concerned that
manipulating viruses may be research
that we are not quite prepared to be
doing
and he warned against what he called
going down a path of
scientific arrogance bill dana
doctor if you could just put a fine
point on this for us
i just want to be very clear about this
redfield's run on the cdc right i mean
they their eyes on this thing probably
in december for sure in january and
february
when did he start thinking about the
virology lab in wuhan
great question bill uh he started
thinking about it at the very beginning
december and january in january
and then he started accumulating
evidence through state department
and the national security council that
verified this
suspicion he had but he told me that the
task force was not focused on that they
were focused on
what was going on here in the united
states so his voice was drowned out bill
i think one of the things that i learned
from there just to really focus in on
was when dr redfield said that we were
because we didn't know about the origins
we in america we're treating this as if
it were a sars-like
um virus which we had dealt with before
but that was the exact
wrong thing to do if we had known that
it was
this other issue that the coronavirus
issue
we would have treated things very
differently and we're about to come up
on the 600 000 uh american to have died
and you think back to that and that
seems to me like that's why you need to
know
how these things get started that's why
china should have cooperated in the
first place
dana that is so true the structure of
the virus according to dr redfield led
to that
massive asymptomatic spread that caused
the virus
to rifle through our communities and how
contagious it was
was specifically due to that and that's
something that the origins play an exact
role in you're absolutely right
this is this is a really another fine
point here as we look back on this doc
asymptomatic spread i i don't believe
that we really understood that until
mid-march because here in new york we
were living our lives in and madison
square garden had
i think ten different events over a span
of
seven to nine days and the wall street
journal did a great analysis of
the hundreds of thousands of people that
would cycle through madison square
garden
for a hockey game or an nba game or
a college basketball game and the
possibility remains that a lot of these
people could have been exposed to it
and that they go out in the community
and over the next 10 to 14 days they're
spreading this
is is that how we now
understand sort of the mistake or the
fault and not understanding cove in the
very beginning like that
completely right bill very well
described listen redfield knew
before almost anyone else he had the
high level clearance and he told me he
wishes he had done a manhattan project
of testing not just a vaccine once he
knew that the asymptomatic spread was so
prominent okay one last thing
the lab leak theory he subscribes to it
based on the world health organization's
report
three months ago in march does he think
the leak was
accidental or done with intent
from everything i've gleaned from that
two hours he does not believe the leak
was accident
was was on purpose that it was
accidental but what was not
accidental was perhaps what was going on
in the lab in the first place
to tweak the virus wow a lot of
revelations there doctor good work
excellent work thank you so much thank
you guys thank you